PASSENGER ARRESTED FOR
SIGHT
ATTENDANT S ONE IN.Y' T
Y DIVERTIN
OOD BATH
I WON'KI Y
JUP YOURANDS AND SAYDON'T KILL
BIRD STRIKE  CAUSED AN EXPLOSIO.
ALSO A COLLISIONEN
SMALL PLANESA AN
THEN THEN
O UNITED ANEPLANES.
WINOFLANEK
IN CONNECTE AN
NUMBERS  S ISIX NEAR RECENT LLIH
THE FAA ISTILY GOES THROUGTH
THESQUR RY
NTIAL FOR AN
HOW MANY OF THOSE NEAR ACCIDENTS
CUER MON?
SO WE'RE AT SOMETHING
BEEIT
TITHAL NUMBER D OF
COSE, IN FEBRUARY, AND IN
RCEE OR FOUR
MORE THAT VEN' GRADED
YET BY FT THE D  TO BE CONTINUI.
>> IS THAT JUS
MOOF JANUAEEMS LIKE D
LINE ON THE MONTH OF F WJU I UL
YOU.
I
LIKE A CONTINUATION OF TREAT ST
T ABOU
>>H.
SO TAD
UNDERSTAND. THAT HAS BEEN GOING
AV20N COMMALLINES AND
NO THE QUOTE, UNQUOTE
E 3
PER .
2.3 PER YE
THENK  DECEMBER OF 202
INJURIES ONT ON
HAWAIIAN FLIGHT.
AND THEN IH  H ATIONS ON JUST
ONE LUFTHANSA  WNINGAHEA
E SORTF NORMGE W
D ERR IN
AND POTENTIALL DEC
GH TIZIOSSARILS ES.
>> ONE >> THIT IN WHICH
VE 11 OUS ,
VERSUS 2 YEAR.
>> ON CL WOULDOROSS INJANUARY A
MORE AIR TRAVE WE'RE U WE HAD PC
UT A MUCH.
IF YOU LOO N INE PASSENGERS THAR
SEBA T
PREPANDEMILEVELS.SO THAT'G GOIN
BUSY RUNWAYS THAT WE EORULY GE
>> SO THERE IS THE ONE BITF
NEWS.
I FEEL LIKE I'VE
GLOOM, NOT MNATURAL STAT
BEING S AR
NUMBERS.
>> REALL
I LIKE TO BE OVER.I CAN'T I HAD
WE HD
LITY
NOT A SINGLE AIRLINEALITONA COM0
, TH
UN PASSENGERS, WE'